Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new Doctor Strange
2 video the actors were talking about what's
going on with the movie.
We have a big update there's a bunch of Easter eggs,
especially with the villains.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do with Doctor
Strange 2 how crazy do you want them to get
with the concept of the multiverse to starting
with number five if you didn't see the news
earlier today Chiwetel Ejiofor did an interview.
He's the actor who plays Baron more dough
during the first Doctor Strange movie.
He confirmed a couple of really huge details
about the plot of Doctor Strange 2 multiverse
of madness and what's going on with the movie
right now, especially given that everything's
been delayed because of the virus explain
what's going on with the villains in because
it's a multiverse movie in a were all expecting
multiverse level villain's even more epic
than the first movie because technically dormammu
was from the multiverse originally they were
supposed to start filming the movie earlier
this year, but because the virus Marvel delayed
every single Marvel phase for movies starting
with black widow originally Doctor Strange
to would've come out next May 2021 now it's
coming out November 2021 when Thor for was
originally supposed to come out.
This is the entire updated schedule for next
year see is the idea, everything just moved
down the release lot previously the Marvel
phase for comic con panel last year Kevin
foggy tease.
The basic premise and plot of Doctor Strange
to in which big characters would be appearing
in how we connect with the rest of the MCU
in marvel phase for because the whole theme
of the next couple of years of the MCU is
the concept of the multiverse there trading
on it very heavily the same way that they
traded on the concept of the infinity gauntlet
in the infinity stones during marvel phase
1.
So Doctor Strange 2 is just about introducing
the MCU to the multiverse in a much much bigger
way they already tease the concept during
the first Doctor Strange movie and even during
Antman the wasp, the kind of dealt with alternate
dimensions alternate realities with the way
the ghost powers worked the quantum realm
quantum energy, it just the other Avengers
only learned about the concepts during Avengers
endgame when they had to explain the concept
of the infinity stones and how they affect
the flow of time in the main reality and the
existence of alternate realities and branching
timelines.
So number four.
The biggest thing is Baron Wargo said that
he's coming back is one of the major villains
of Doctor Strange 2 I think we assume that
he would come back.
Based in the way he left in the first movie,
but no one it Marvel had conferred until now.
So now it's official.
He is coming back the last we saw them at
the end of the first Doctor Strange movie
he'd become disillusioned with the institution
of the sanctum's in the ancient one.
After believing that she betrayed everything
that he stood for his whole concept of ordered
Justice right and wrong as it applies to the
use of magic.
He says there's a reckoning coming for all
of them for their misuse of magic in the bill
always comes due.
So the difference now heading into Doctor
Strange 2 after Avengers endgame is that
he has views himself as the instrument of
that reckoning is also part of the reason
why you probably didn't see him in this giant
Avengers roster lineup because he superpowerful
he could help them against Santos, but he
still doesn't really like what they're doing
in the way people are using magic is all beef
with the ancient one was when she revealed
that she been using dark magic from dorm Amu's
dimension in order to prolong her life, so
that she could continue to protect the main
MCU version of Earth from threats from outside
our dimension like dorm Amu while also continuing
to search for her inevitable replacement.
She said that she actually use the time stone
to view alternate possible futures until she
found ones were Doctor Strange showed up.
That's kind of how Doctor Strange got the
idea to use the time stone during Avengers
infinity war to look into the 14 million futures
to find the one scenario where they could
beat the Enos, so more dough cuts ties with
the sanctum and then in that post credit scene
removes all the traces of magical power from
Benjamin Pratt's character who had previously
left the sanctum after learning to use magic
just to regain the use of his legs.
He basically strips him of all his magic saying
they're entirely too many sorcerers which
is a reference to the source or supreme who
by that time to become Doctor Strange, so
Moreau himself is on a quest to balance the
scale, so to speak.
Enacting his reckoning across the world getting
rid of magic users that he things aren't following
the rules of magic, number three, which is
where we come to the Doctor Strange scarlet
which team up in the movie to scarlet which
is going to be one of the main characters
during Doctor Strange 2 Kevin Feige said
that there Wandavision series will also cross
over with the movie like it's a prequel to
Doctor Strange 2 and during that Marvel is
going to make scarlet which go full comic
book scarlet which chaos magic and all that's
why they're teasing the X-Men classic comic
book outfit and is a lot of people have commented
the reason why this looks like a Halloween
costume version of her comic book outfit is
probably because in context in this episode,
it is a Halloween costume that she's wearing.
Remember, they're doing this funny sitcom
troops with the different decades and genres
during one of them is probably a party and
she's wearing this costume to that party in
the episode, so whatever's happening here
ill just make way more sense when we actually
see the episode, but this all means that scarlet
which is the newest as tier magic user in
the MCU and Baron Margo is trying to restrict
the use of magic.
So that would put her on his radar, the kind
of going the Loki route with Baron more dough
in the MCU.
He's not necessarily evil.
He is gonna kill Doctor Strange or anything
like that.
He's believes that there a lot of people out
there misusing magic in his clinically to
another major catastrophe house of M style
ever talk about scarlet which references so
number two the real main villain of the movie
as of last year was still going to be the
cosmic entity nightmare from the nightmare
dimension, but that was when Scott Erickson
was still writing and directing the movie
he left the project earlier this year in Chiwetel
Ejiofor also just confirmed that Sam Raimi
will in fact direct the movie we heard the
news earlier this year, but Marvel hadn't
really made a big statement about all the
trades reported it seem like it was confirmed
now, it just seems like it's deftly confirm
if the actor who the main star the movie is
saying that Sam Raimi is directing it.
So for Raimi is on the movie now and they're
going with a different screenwriter to write
the script as possible that they chose to
go with the different big bad but will see
it be mighty cool them to tease Mephisto during
Wandavision and then have them show up during
Doctor Strange 2 in a much bigger way.
He's also one of the few big villains that
scarlet which in Doctor Strange share in common
big Doctor Strange villain also separately
big scarlet which villain I visited a big
Easter eggs video for the first Avengers movie
as part of my infinity saga rewatch series
the past few months and during the first Avengers
movie, they subtly reference Mephisto on screen
their plans for the character at that time
were very different and they ended up not
using him as part of that version of the infinity
gauntlet storyline.
The reason Scott Erickson said he wanted to
use nightmare is the main villain is because
he was fascinated by the idea that nightmares
could be a real thing that could threaten
you from another dimension controlled by this
giant cosmic fear Lord.
The whole concept of nightmare is that he's
only able to affect people when they're in
deep sleep states because something about
the barrier between dimensions is much weaker
at that point for each person, presumably
in his version of the movies scarlet which
or someone else would have been responsible
for weakening the barriers between dimensions
enough so that nightmare could physically
enter our dimension insert turning people's
nightmares into reality.
If her talk about powers Mephisto is a little
bit different usually winds of tricking people
into really rotten bargains, so everyone Queue
up your Doctor Strange means Mephisto.
I've come to bargain in number one, because
is a multiverse movie big crossovers alternate
versions of major characters, everyone is
still freaking out about the Michael Keaton
Batman news the last couple of days.
He's coming back as a multiverse Batman in
the DC movies for real.
No joke.
He's coming back as an older version of his
Batman from the 1989 Batman movie, so now
everyone is expecting Marvel the go the extra
mile with its multiverse movie and have alternate
versions of major characters and here's a
really cool thing about that Kevin foggy back
in comic con already said that we see alternate
versions of major characters.
He just didn't say which ones now because
Sam Raimi is directing the movie and he's
like Mr. Spider-Man in terms of comic book
movies.
I know everyone is hoping for some sort of
Toby McGuire Spider-Man Easter egg in reference
but also expect to see other major Avengers
characters to we will just be one alternate
version of a character without them going
to overboard on the concept that the planet
can into an alternate version of Ironman just
because we kind of undercut his sacrifice
during Avengers endgame save all the Ironman
cameos for the next big Avengers multiverse
movie like secret wars, or something like
that Chiwetel Ejiofor also said they be filming
the movie very soon, which based on what's
happening around the world with them restarting
movie productions means probably sometime
in August.
There is some small pickups that marvels filming
for one division and falcon winter soldier
in July, but their biggest movies probably
won't get going again until early August and
for the most part all the stuff that was supposed
to come this year.
Like falcon winter soldier episodes in Wandavision
episodes are still going to come for the most
part this year, but because of all those delays
we probably won't get the first Doctor Strange
to trailer until they release the eternal's
movie next February.
They haven't announced all their comic con
plans yet but because DC is doing a special
virtual comic con on their own Marvel might
wind up doing the same thing whatever they
wind up doing.
Of course I'll do videos for as much of it
as possible leave all your requests in the
comments below and let me know which alternate
versions of characters do you want to see
pop up in Doctor Strange 2 point it made
your point for everyone post all your Spider-Man
into the spider verse means while you wait
for everything.
Click here to learn all about Michael Keaton
coming back his Batman in new DC movies and
click here for that brand-new Marvel Avengers
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe, I'll see you guys tonight!